James Comey gets his two-hour special
president Trump's attack attack Syria
and the March for science takes place it
is massive meaning no one showed up I
mention Pierrot this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
so as you can tell I am in fine form
this morning I'm here with a cold and up
at 5:00 in the morning since my wife is
on rotation so everything is awesome but
don't worry everything is also awesome
in the world of politics I will describe
for you all of the crazy that happened
over the weekend no Disneyland for
anyone I took my kids to Disneyland
yesterday if you're a fan of mine and
you were there yesterday that was
strictly forbidden
you're not allowed because obviously I
told you not to ruin things over the
weekend as always and I said there would
be no Disneyland for you if you did
continue to ruin things name yet things
have been ruined and I will discuss all
of those things in just a minute first I
want to say thanks to our sponsor is
over at keeps so keeps is the easiest
way to keep your hair right now you're
thinking I'm a young buck I'm not gonna
lose my hair anytime soon wrong you are
take a look at your pops and the good
shot is your hair will be gone before
you know it which is why you need keeps
keeps offers the only two hair loss
products that are clinically proven to
keep the hair that you have you can sign
up in less than five minutes and keeps
it entirely online only ten bucks to 35
bucks a month so it's a buck a day or
less on average which is half of what
you typically pay at the pharmacy and
getting started is really really easy
all you do is go to keeps calm and then
a licensed doctor will remotely review
your information and give you the right
prescription all without ever leaving
your coucher than two to three days a
three-month supply of your treatment
will arrive perfectly packaged at your
door so keep your hair the easy way with
keeps offering customized treatment
plans with the only clinically proven
hair loss products for about a buck a
day from the comfort of your couch
receive your first month of treatment
for free go to keep us calm slash Ben
that's ke EPS calm slash ban that's a
free month of treatment it keeps calm
slash men again keeps hair today hair
tomorrow and if you're looking for the
the only products that are clinically
proven to keep the hair you have keeps
the place to get them keeps calm slash
pen that's ke EPS calm slash Ben go
check it out now before it's too late
and your hair is gone and you just sit
here regretfully thinking about what if
you just listened and done what shapiro
told you to do that's why you need to go
to keeps calm slash baton alrighty so
the big news over the weekend is little
twofold number one there was an attack
on Syria which we'll discuss in a little
bit and second of all James Comey sat
down with George Stephanopoulos of ABC
News so first of all it is always
obligatory whenever I mentioned James
Comey Ave whenever I mentioned George
Stephanopoulos of ABC News I must recall
he was the former chief of staff for the
Clintons so this is a guy who
very tied into the Democratic Network I
mentioned that not because I thought he
did a particularly terrible job last
night in the interview but to point out
that the media are wildly biased in
favor of James Comey who is playing one
of the great scams of all timing the guy
was largely responsible for Hillary
Clinton losing the election and now he's
going to retire off of Democrats who are
angry that Hillary Clinton lost the
election so well done James Comey I mean
that is a scam for the ages that is
usual suspects type stuff just
incredible stuff so James Cummings is a
full two-hour interview with George
Stephanopoulos on ABC News did he have
anything brand-new shocking to say not
really it was mainly vindictive and and
self gratifying and self-justifying and
now that's that's what it was it was
James Comey grandstanding at his best
there are a few takeaways from this
interview it was kind of interesting he
had some interesting things to say but I
have to say the amount of ego that was
just pouring off the screen was
incredible the amount of smog between
Stephanopoulos and James Comey it is
amazing that the world did not implode
from simple overload of smug and I
should know I mean I'm pretty smug dude
but let me tell you something James
Comey and George Stephanopoulos
outclassed me by at least a couple of
weight classes it's pretty impressive
James Comey started out the interview by
saying quote I was never going to write
a book but I decided I had to try to
write this one to try and be useful that
was my goal after I was fired to be
useful and it occurred to me maybe I can
be useful by offering a view to people
especially to young people
of what leadership should look like and
how it should be centered on values in
other words maybe I should write a book
talking about how awesome I am
in order to inform all the young people
about how awesome I am so they too can
one day be awesome like I am or
alternative explanation you're fired and
you want to make a lot of money I'm
gonna go with that one are you're gonna
giant advance and sell hundreds of
thousands of copies of your ebook
I'm pretty much gonna say that that's
probably what James Comey was doing it
probably wasn't like you know what
I'm out of office now what do I have to
do you know what I'm gonna go home I'm
gonna look over my flower garden I'm
gonna write about leadership because
that's what young people need today
leadership no it's probably the whole
selling lots of books things and then he
goes on in the interview to rip on
president Trump II of course says that
Trump is a forest fire going to do
tremendous damage going to damage
important norms but a forest fire gives
healthy things a chance to grow they had
no chance before that fire and the
entire interview is just incredibly
self-serving my favorite metaphor that
he used for himself as he said that when
he went to the White House to talk to
President Trump he said there's a
movie called The Sixth Sense then I talk
about in the book where Bruce Willis
doesn't realize he's dead that's the way
I felt I felt like I was totally alone
that everybody hated me and there wasn't
the way out because it was really the
right thing to do he's talking about now
going to the White House to talk to
President Obama about revealing the fact
that Hillary Clinton's emails had been
found on Anthony Weiner server and that
in a way I'm ruined but that's what I
have to do I had to do it that way what
a hero he's just like Bruce Willis from
The Sixth Sense guys it's just amazing
he's walking around he's dead he doesn't
know at the entire time
spoiler alert shame his company don't
worry though
he doesn't have ego this is a man who is
completely free from ego what what a
wonderful man he has throughout the
interview he praises President Obama jeh
Johnson the former Department of
Homeland Security Secretary he says that
he wishes Hillary Clinton would read the
book so that she would know why he did
what he did during the election cycle
and then of course he dumped on Trump
personally so here was James Comey
dumping on president Trump personally
this is clip 7 it was the first time he
met Donald Trump what was your
impression he had impressively quaffed
hair it looks to be all his I confess I
stared at it pretty closely and my
reaction was must take a heck of a lot
of time in the morning his tie was too
long as it always is he looked slightly
orange up close with small white half
moons under his eyes which I assume are
from tanning goggles ok so this is
definitely the kind of image that James
Comey wants to project right he wants to
protect WOM an image and that's what a
law man would do I mean that's really if
you were if you were just like Jimmy
Stewart g-man and you order to give an
interview about a president who you
thought might be corrupt the first thing
you do is talk about the half-moons
under his eyes and the length of his tie
then that really makes James Comey look
real good here I mean this is obviously
not somebody he was writing a book about
leadership guys a book about leadership
for children that was his goal it was
not to be the center of attention no not
he not he and then of course Jim's
coming like to drop a bunch of
inflammatory lines in the middle of this
interview because there really is
nothing new in the book other than him
whining about President Trump and
talking about President Trump is
terrible now whatever you think about
Trump they're two separate questions
right is Trump corrupt has Trump done
things that are ill-advised has
president Trump interfered in
investigations right these are all legit
questions but what is not really a legit
question is whether James Comey is a
politically motivated actor he's pretty
clearly a politically motive
that's pretty obvious when he admitted
on camera that when he went to speak
with President Trump you recall he went
to speak James Comey former FBI director
when he was when Trump first was about
to take office we went to brief him he
briefed him on the Russian dossier the
steel dossier had been compiled by a
British spy named Christopher Steele it
had been paid for by fusion GPS which
was being paid for in turn by Hillary
Clinton's law firm and James Comey did
not reveal to President Trump that this
dossier had been gathered at the behest
of Hillary Clinton's pay right he admits
that in clip eight did you tell him that
the steel dust he had been financed by
his political opponents no I didn't had
any think I used the term steel dosia I
just talked about additional material
but did he have a right to know that
that had been financed by his political
opponents I don't know the answer to
that it wasn't necessary for my goal
which is to alert him that we had this
information well who cares about your
goal he's the president of the United
States don't you owe him that
information I mean you work for him
you're the head of the FBI and the FBI
is an executive branch agency shouldn't
you have told him that the steel dossier
was funded by Hillary Clinton wouldn't
that been a little bit important for him
to know but again the goal here is to is
form for James Comey to obviously come
off as above the fray well he didn't
come off as above the fray anywhere in
this interview there's an enormous
amount of self-serving material in this
interview and of course he's giving the
press everything spicy they want to is
clip nine available do we have clip nine
okay so in there at one point during the
interview Comey is asked specifically
about the P tape and here's what he said
he said and then Trump said to me
another reason you know it's not true is
I'm a germaphobe there's no ID let
people pee on each other around me and
that caught me so much by surprise I
actually let out inaudible laughs and
because it was just one of those I was
startled by it and I remember thinking
well should I say that as I understand
the activity sir it doesn't require an
overnight stay
and given that was allegedly the
presidential suite at the Ritz Carlton I
would imagine you could be a safe
distance from the activity all these
things are bouncing around my head but
instead of saying it just led me to
think the world's gone crazy but again
the goal here for James Comey is to sell
as many books as humanly possible
there are really three scandals in which
James Comey is is involved right scandal
number one is the Hillary Clinton issue
right the Hillary Clinton issue scandal
number two is the Russian issue with
president Trump and skeletal number
three is firing there are three separate
issues and in each one the story he
tells is really
not particularly great okay so the
Hillary handling itself was bad first of
all let's get out of the way how much he
hates President Trump the man just hates
President Trump so here are several
clips of him talking about how much he
hates President Trump here is where he
compares President Trump to a crime
family again
I'm not sure why no political advisor
set Co me down and said you know James
it might be worthwhile for you to appear
not to hate President Trump if you
actually want to go after him right you
might want to look as they were
disinterested rather than that you have
a personal animus toward him apparently
nobody bothered telling him so instead
he compares Trump to a crime family I
had a flashback to my days investigating
the Mafia look cosa nostra is the
distinction between a friend of yours
and a friend of ours I felt this effort
to make us all maybe this wasn't their
intention but it's the way I felt to me
to make us all a Mika Nostra we're all
part of the messaging we're all part of
the effort the boss is at the head of
the table we're gonna figure out
together how to do this how strange is
it for you to sit here and compare the
president to a mob boss
well okay come on and what kind of
question is that George Stephanopoulos
how strange is if he's doing it on
purpose to sell books you idiots but of
course George Stephanopoulos knows that
he's not an idiot
okay that was not all that Comey had to
say about President Trump personally and
then he talked about how Trump was
morally unfit to be presidents as clip
16 as is Trump talking this is Comey
talking about how Trump is just unfit
right again a lot of this is being
driven by the fact that Comey is angry
that Trump fired him you write the
president Trump is unethical untethered
to the truth he is Donald Trump unfit to
be President
yes but not in the way I often hear
people talk about it I don't buy this
stuff about him being mentally
incompetent the early stages of dementia
he strikes me as a person of
above-average intelligence who's
tracking conversations and knows what's
going on I don't think he's medically
unfit to be President I think he's
morally unfit to people okay and then he
continued exactly along these lines
hey again talking about how Trump has
been compromised by the Russians he says
that it's possible the Russians
compromised from now again he doesn't
have any evidence of this anything's
possible
anything's possible does George
Stephanopoulos follow up by saying did
you have evidence that the Russians have
compromised Trump no of course not they
just sort of let it hang out there
there's James Comey saying that it's
possible that Trump is compromised by
the
Asians do you think the Russians have
something on Donald Trump I think it's
possible I don't know maybe these are
more words I never thought I'd about a
president United States but it's
possible that's stunning you can't say
for certain that the president United
States is not compromised by the
Russians yeah it is stunning and I wish
I wasn't saying it but it's just it's
the truth
great interviewing there again great
interviewing there again by George
Stephanopoulos just reiterate the point
that is stunning what you're saying I'm
not gonna ask you for any evidence of
what you're saying but it is stunning
that you would even say that mr. Fehmi
just incredibly stunning again the goal
here for Comey is to sell books the goal
here for George Stephanopoulos is to use
Comey as baton in order to club
president Trump okay that is the goal
here now we can talk about in a second
exactly what Comey did during the
Hillary scandal during the Trump
investigation and to get fired we'll
talk about all that in just a second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at thrive market so thrive
market is the best place to buy your
organic food okay it is the best place
to get your healthy food you can shop
for thousands of the best selling
non-gmo foods and natural products
always at 25 to 50% below traditional
retail prices that's what thrive market
is for so you're never gonna have to go
to Whole Foods which is overpriced and
you have to get stuck in the tiny
parking lots with the Priuses again
instead you go to thrive market online
more than 70% in the private market
catalog cannot be found on Amazon
they're the largest retailer in the
country that tells exclusively non-gmo
groceries and you can catalog everything
by your values and dietary preferences
it doesn't matter if you're paleo or
gluten-free or vegan or kosher like me
you can shop for 90 plus values also
including non-gmo sustainably farmed
Fairtrade certified bpa-free more in
just one click of a button you never
have to read a label again because
thrive market does all of the homework
for you and in each product page you can
see things like why I love it price
comparisons price comparisons to retail
nutritional ingredients many of the
product pages even include the brand's
background story and why the product is
safe for your family here's how it works
go over to thrive market calm slash
Shapiro and users get $20 off their
first three orders of 49 bucks or more
plus free shipping most shoppers spend
more than 49 bucks on the site anyway do
the math you spend 49 bucks and thrive
automatically gives you back 20 bucks
your total purchase becomes 30 bucks and
you get this deal three times in a row
go over to thrive market calm slash
Shapiro thrive market calm slash prepare
to get your instance $60 of free
groceries thrive market calm slash
here again it is easy to shop there it
is cheaper to shop there it is healthier
to shop there go to thrive market calm /
appear oh and never bother going your
local your local organic grocery store
again with all of the with all the the
the crazed Hillary voters their thrive
market calm / Shapiro and you can safely
shop for healthy great food in the
anonymity of your own home thrive market
calm / appear get your instant 60 bucks
of free groceries all right so let's go
call me in his book he talks about
really three separate things he talks
about the Hillary investigation he talks
about the Trump investigation on Russia
and then he talked about being fired and
so what he says about Hillary
demonstrates what a political actor he
is right so recall the back in July it
was James Comey who came out and made a
long statement basically about why
Hillary Clinton in viola violated the
law but should not be indicted remember
he said that she had been extremely
careless with her emails which is the
definition of gross negligence under the
law and then he says we won't indict her
anyway we shouldn't have indicted her
anyway right so now he says he shouldn't
have describes how sloppy Clinton was
with all of her with all of her email
server stuff was trying to be honest and
clear with the American people what she
did was really sloppy okay he says what
she did was really sloppy but he says
that he made a mistake describing how
sloppy she was with her email scandal
because in doing so it made it look like
she had violated the law when in his
opinion she's not actually violated the
law then later he says that the reason
that he came forward with the letter
remember the letter right before the
election in which he says that hundreds
of thousands of her emails were found on
Anthony Weiner's a computer and then he
says that he released a letter a few
days before the election now he says the
reason that he did that is because the
polling showed that Hillary was really
far up in the polls and if she won he
didn't want this cloud to be over her
presidency so he says I came out with
that letter just to be completely
transparent and he says that assuming
Hillary would have won probably
influenced his decision-making
remember consciously thinking about that
but it must have been because I was
operating in a world where Hillary
Clinton was gonna beat Donald Trump and
so I'm sure that it that it was a factor
like I said I don't remember spelling it
out but it had to have been that that
she's gonna be elected president and if
I hide this from the American people
she'll be a legitimate the moment she's
elected so he's so above the fray don't
you see how above the fray James Comey
is he's such a non political actor what
a good guy he is you know he wants to
exonerate Hill
Clinton before the election or less he
wants the American public to know about
this stuff so that when she's elected
then she'll be clean but don't worry
he's totally above the fray you can see
how upset he was the Trump was elected
because he literally says in this
interview oh my god did we have some
role in this
it is legitimately what Comey says in
the middle of this interview and what
part of you is thinking I helped elect
Donald Trump a whole lot of me was
thinking oh my god did we have some role
in this did we have some impact on the
election okay well why would you be
thinking that let's say that you
actually were the typical g-man let's
say that you Tim but you were the
Honorable FBI guy the loyal FBI guy that
James Comey says he is wouldn't you just
abide by the law instead of saying oh my
god were we part of this wouldn't you
just said listen the law says I have to
do X this is what I have to do and
therefore no you know that had no impact
on my decision-making I did what I had
to do that's my job
I'm above personal petty grievances I'm
above personal petty politics but he had
no intention of saying any of that
because of course it's not true the
reality is that James Comey is not above
personal petty politics as we've seen he
hasn't like President Trump he was very
disappointed when Trump won it's pretty
obvious or now he's at least
disappointed that he was fired and so
he's trying to drag out every piece of
dirt he can on President Trump he's
trying to dump that out in the public
view but he really doesn't have a lot
there and so it's all speculation maybe
Trump obstructed justice maybe he's
gonna be blackmailed by the Russians
when there's no they're there all you
have to do is dump out a bunch of
inflammatory material the media will
pick it up and try and run with it
okay well now in the meantime President
Trump is firing back so President Trump
takes to Twitter and and here are some
of the things that President Trump has
been tweeting about James Comey quote
Comey drafted the crooked Hillary
exoneration long before he talked to her
lied in Congress to Senator G then based
his decision I'm her poll numbers
disgruntled he mccabe and the others
committed many crimes okay so all of
this is true I just don't know why
President Trump feels the necessity to
go out there and say it because again
you know I look I know President Trump
is a counter puncher I know that he
doesn't like like homey saying about him
but this is not productive the president
should shut up all he's doing is driving
the president all he's doing is driving
the the news cycle all he's doing is
driving people to buy the book the same
way that he drove the fire in fury
book to the top of the bestseller list
now he's gonna help dr james Combes book
to the top and bestseller lists if you
can somehow get Trump to attack you and
you're on the bestseller and you're
you're in the book market that is the
best way to sell books Trump continues
along these lines he tweets slippery
James Comey a man who always ends up
badly and out of whack he is not smart
exclamation point will go down as the
worst FBI director in history by far
again don't know what useful how useful
it stations I never asked call me for
personal loyalty I hardly even knew the
guy just another of his many lies his
memos are self-serving and all caps fake
but he's not done yet he continues Comey
throws attorney general Lynch under the
bus in quotation marks for some reason
why can't we all find out what happened
on the tarmac in the back of the plane
with Wild Bill and Lynch well she
promised a Supreme Court seat or AG in
order to laugh Hillary no golf and
grandkids talk give us all a break okay
but is he done yet nope the president
has even more the big questions in
Kobe's badly reviewed book aren't
answered like how come he came up
classified information jail why did he
lie to Congress jail why did the DNC
refused to give server to the FBI why
didn't they take it why the phony memos
became 700,000 dollars and more okay and
and so you know this is you know
President Trump on the warpath on
Twitter obviously now here's the reality
everything that I everything he's saying
in this Twitter thread is true
everything he is saying about Comey and
this Twitter thread is true again the
question is not true or not true the
question is useful or not useful when
the president's taxco me and called me
attacks the president Trump is punching
down and he's allowing Comey to go out
there and respond to him he's allowing
Comey to go out there and tell his side
of the story with a broader public
appeal it's not smart of the president
to punch back in this particular way
even though I think that Comey is
exposing himself for what he is a thief
he concluded this Twitter thread Trump
said by saying unbelievably James Comey
states that polls we're crooked Hillary
was leading we're a factor in handling
stupidly of the Clinton email probe in
other words he was making decisions
based on the fact he thought she was
going to win and he wanted a job
slimeball okay so I guess we have
slippery James crow me and and slimeball
James call me the president really going
after it on Twitter really enjoying
himself
yeah again he has the right to do
whatever he wants so I think this is
highly useful
I do not especially because commis
getting himself in hot water with a
bunch of people right not just folks on
the right he's now got himself in hot
water
Loretta Lynch the former Attorney
General at the time said James Comey has
accused Obama and Loretta Lynch of
taking actions that jeopardize the goj
status in the middle of the Hillary
Clinton email investigations what he
says is when Loretta Lynch got on the
plane with Bill Clinton that
necessitated the FBI stepping in and
making some sort of argument as to why
Hillary should or should not be indicted
because obviously now people are gonna
think the whole thing was corrupt
well now Loretta Lynch is firing back on
called me and suggesting that Comey is
terrible she says over almost two
decades as a federal prosecutor I've
aggressively prosecuted drug dealers
federal gangs very violent gangs
mobsters and money launderers upheld the
civil rights of all Americans and fought
corruption of all types whether my
elected officials from both sides of the
aisle or within organizations like
Pfeiffer that's the soccer organization
through it all I've never hesitated to
make the hard decisions guided by the
Department of Justice's core principles
of integrity independence and above all
always doing the right thing the Justice
Department's handling of the Clinton
email investigation under my leadership
was no exception any suggestion I
invoked this bedrock policy for any
reason is simply false
throughout the process I do I always do
rise above my politics and uphold the
law does anyone really believe Loretta
Lynch rose above her politics top hold
the law does anyone truly believe that
well neither did James Comey hey you
wonder why people don't trust the
so-called deep State at this point is
because it's filled with people who are
political appointees and these political
appointees have actual access to grind
and so you know what's the best way for
you to appear above the law by being
above the law by being above the law by
by acting as though you are above or
rather by being above politics you want
to appear as though you're above
politics all you have to do is be above
politics but none of these people are
and that is eminently obvious at this
point in time well in just a second I'm
gonna get to Syria plus the March for
science happening over the weekend but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsor is over at Skillshare so folks
are moving jobs pretty routinely in this
market which is a good thing it means
that you're going for a raise or you
getting a better job but in order for
you to get that raise or that better job
you need to make your skillset better
and that's where Skillshare comes in
it's an online learning platform with
over 18,000 classes and designed
business technology and more you can
take classes in graphic design social
media marketing illustration mobile
photography
they've got classes and pretty much
everything there these 45 minute classes
taught by experts over at the office
we've taken search engine optimization
we've taken social media marketing I've
taken a course in watercolor painting
believe it or not gotta calm down
for the day that's what Skillshare is
therefore join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today and
they have a special offer just for my
listeners right now get two months of
Skillshare for just 99 cents so
Skillshare is offering my listeners
again two months of unlimited access to
over 18,000 classes for just 99 cents
once you start learning you're not going
to want to stop to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash shapiro again that
skill shared comm slash Shapiro to start
your two months right now that
Skillshare comm slash Shapiro again not
just 99 cents for those two months of
unlimited access and they've got classes
in pretty much everything if you're
looking to make that resume better or
you're just starting a side business and
you need more and you need more skills
in order to start that side business
that is what Skillshare is there for and
as I say we use it around the office all
of their classes are just first-rate try
Skillshare comm slash capiro that skill
shared comm slash Shapiro and you get
18,000 classes for just 99 cents for two
months which is pretty awesome skill
shared comm slash apparel use that slash
Shapiro so they know that we say you
okay so meanwhile the march for science
happened over the weekend and the March
for science is stupid okay the reason I
say the March for science is stupid is
because it is not a March for actual
science because as Dave Burge over Iowa
ha put it
that's like saying I'm going to go dance
for architecture right what does that
even mean March for science dance for
architecture preach for mathematics like
what are what are you even talking about
there's no such thing as a march for
science because everyone that I know is
pro science like if you wanna say you're
anti Flat Earth right like there's three
people who still believe in the Flat
Earth or let's say that you want to say
you're gonna march for Cap'n
cap-and-trade right that's an actual
policy you're marching for one of the
things that drives me most crazy is when
you name your March something that is
universally applicable and then claim
that anyone who opposes your marches
against those things when you say March
for our lives right this is the pro gun
control March so there's a pro gun
control March and they call it March
fertilised so I don't they just call it
March for gun control well because then
we'd all be able to be pro or against it
when they say March for our lives the
implication is that if I opposed your
agenda I want you to die which of course
is not true well they're now doing the
same thing with science they have their
march for science and if you say listen
this March is really dumb because all
you're preaching here is non scientific
stuff then they say well no that's
because you hate science that's the real
issue here you hate science first of all
I will just point out the media coverage
of the March for science was
blowing much more going to the March for
Life Everest the March for life is
always under covered the march for life
of course is the pro-life March that
happens in Washington DC each and every
year and the and the march for science
was way down in attendance so last year
a bunch of people showed up to March
because in 2017 you could get people to
March for virtually anything because
they were angry about Trump
she said March for chicken and people
would be out in the streets going we
hate Trump we Haley millions of people
in the streets marching for chicken well
now people are not showing up for the
March for science because they better
things to do but listen to how CNN
describes the March for science it's
pretty incredible they say quote
Saturday's crowds were notably smaller
than those that showed up for the first
march in April 2017 but attendees
expressed as much optimism and hope as
they did last year really is that news
coverage nobody showed up but they
expressed just as much hope and optimism
as they did last year can we have
scientific measure it's a match for
science can we have a scientific measure
of the hope and optimism please can we
know by what specific percentage the
hope and optimism were up or down over
the last year real scientific writing
there in the March for science CNN sure
half the people showed up but let me
tell you their spirit is what counted it
was their heart that mattered it was
that so much enthusiasm so much optimism
so did they actually talk about science
did they get up there and lecture about
physics did they start doing Bernoulli's
formula like what is it is this their
thing no that's not what they did
instead they talked about racial
diversity amongst scientists quote the
challenges are real for underrepresented
students in science and Cory Welch
director of the stem Scholars Program at
Iowa State University we have to
overcome the reality that few or no
faculty share our identities or fully
understand our situation on campus and
now we have to relate back to our
communities the diversity research
clearly demonstrates bringing all people
to the table to the scientific table I
don't know what the scientific table is
know like the table of elements leads to
better ideas kinder more ethical
solutions and always a more informed
public policy this is what Welch says
and the Cori Walsh the director of
science technology and math at Iowa
State University
ok does any of that sound scientific to
you or does that sound like a bunch of
garbled nonsense
because let me tell you something it
isn't scientific ok studies do not show
in fact that that racial diversity leads
to better ideas kinds or more ethical
solutions or a more informed public
policy
is untrue Robert Putnam of Harvard
University who is a leftist says quote
the only two things that go up is the
diversity of your census track goes up
our protest marches and television
watching so if we're going to pretend
that like because we have a couple of
black scientists in the room they have
black answers to scientific questions
this sounds suspiciously like idiotic
eugenic policy in the early 20th century
like really I again I failed to under
you want talk about something that is
wildly anti-scientific it is the idea
that racial diversity has anything to do
with scientific discovery that's
ridiculous
the ideas have to do with scientific
discovery there are great black
scientists there great white scientists
their blackness or whiteness have
nothing to do with their with their
quality as scientists nothing zero
things you know why because science is
verifiable or non verifiable and your
race has nothing to do with whether your
scientific experiment is verifiable or
non verifiable science is perfectly
objective or at least it should be and
yet we are being told that the march for
science that one of their chief goals is
to ensure that there are more black
people in the sciences what does that
have to do with marching for science if
you understand its march for affirmative
action fine that's at least honest but
how are you gonna say that's a march for
science and of course it's not a march
for science this is incredibly stupid a
Nazi policy by the way is that there was
such anything as Jewish science Jewish
science was that weird Einstein ian's
stuff you know the stuff that actually
led to the creation of the nuclear bomb
that end in World War two if the
honestly if the Nazis had not been
anti-jewish and they had been able to
harness the intellectual firepower of
all the Jews living in their society
there's a good shot the Nazis would have
had a nuclear weapon before the United
States didn't Oliver world of history
would have changed thank God they were a
bunch of horrible racist pieces of human
filth and therefore they thought there
was such a thing as Jewish science
versus non-jewish science and they threw
all the Jews out it turns out there
isn't such a thing as Jewish or
non-jewish science there's just science
well again the people who are in the
white coats it doesn't matter what race
they are so long as they're actually
pursuing science but the March for
science has nothing to do with science
this guy named Adam best who's a
left-winger on Twitter he tweeted quote
hey conservatives mocking marks for
science logout of Twitter get off your
phone or computer power down AC
refrigerators and TVs flip off the
lights stop taking medication or
supplements pee and poop outside no
driving cars either show science who's
boss merica okay this is ridiculous
again the reason to oppose the march for
science is because it had nothing
to do with science it has to do with
science but science is not the same as
science okay so science is just like you
know verifiable data and you do
experiments with hypotheses and they're
either and they're they're shown to be
correct the hypotheses are not science
however it's just a bunch of left-wing
terminology right it's it's
cap-and-trade and diverse racial
diversity above all and again a bunch of
assumptions you're making about policy
that may or may not be true but
certainly are not verified by any sort
of hard scientific research if this
idiot atom best can show me what a March
for science has to do with creating a
cellphone then I'm happy to put down my
cell phone but it has nothing to with it
just alright I hate to break it to the
folks on the left but the March for
science was never about science in the
first place and it is the extremism of
the left that is so galling today with
with the march for science there's a
piece by Jonathan Chait over at New York
Magazine it's amazing the left has so
little self-awareness I mean a
tremendous lack of self-awareness
Jonathan Chait wrote a piece in New York
magazine today asking why so many
Republicans had not jumped to the
Democratic Party after President Trump
was elected the piece was called the
gops never Trump errs are really just
never Democrats and then he criticized
David Brooks of the New York Times who
suggested the Democrats ought to reach
out to Republicans and chaid road
instead quote perhaps the Republican
base as currently constituted is
hopelessly immune to reason and a
reasonable person such as Brooks should
instead refocus his political energies
on curtailing its political power so his
take is that if you were really a good
Republican you'd be a Democrat if you
were really a good conservative who
didn't like president Trump enough you
would Justin voted for Hillary Clinton
here's what she writes the idea of
abandoning the Republican Party because
it is authoritarian and toxically
anti-intellectual was apparently as
unfathomable unfathomable to David
Brooks as efficient a polluted river
decided to live on land if you want to
understand why in events as large and
potentially cataclysmic as the election
of Donald Trump has not yet scrambled
the long trench warfare stalemate
between red and blue America this
dynamic is a good place to start she's
trying to figure out why it is that
people didn't jump from not supporting
Trump to supporting Democrats I give him
a very simple answer Democrats are
extreme leftists that's why yeah I would
never have voted for Hillary Clinton
even though I did not vote for President
Trump yeah I would never have voted for
Hillary Clinton because Hillary Clinton
is a wild leftist who not only disagrees
with me on policy she thinks I'm an ax
pleura believing the babies before birth
deserve the right to life and believing
that
my church or synagogue ought to be able
to do whatever it damn well pleases she
thinks I'm a bad person for thinking
that why would I possibly vote for
Hillary Clinton
I think her viewpoint is anti-american
why would I possibly vote for her just
because I didn't approve a president
Trump's comments about grabbing women by
the bleep it's ridiculous
it's a ridiculous argument she is making
here it's the extremism of the left that
is driving people to the right it's a
major factor it's been in just a second
I'm gonna explain a little bit more
about this first you're gonna have to go
over to Daley wire calm and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire when you do
get the rest of this show live get the
rest of Andrew Clavin show live you get
the rest of Michael Noel's show live you
also get extra segments of my show
occasionally plus you get to be part of
the mailbag which you will be doing on
Friday a little bit later in the week so
if you subscribe now you actually get to
ask questions and have them lands to
have them answered live on air also with
the annual subscription you get this
the leftist year's hot or cold tumbler
and I will demonstrate full scale this
week how this thing can cure the common
cold okay I've got a cold you'll see by
the end of the week my cold will be gone
because of this because I wanna see
correlation equals causation but it
might it might ok so just check that out
$99 a year you got the annual
subscription which comes along with the
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr check
that out you want to listen later for
free go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube download our show please
subscribe please leave a sort of you we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so back to Jonathan traits piece at the
New York Magazine so he's arguing again
that Republicans should have become
Democrats if they didn't like president
Trump enough they didn't like president
Trump's and they should have just voted
Hillary Clinton he says quote the idea
of abandoning the Republican Party is
because of his authoritarian and
toxically anti-intellectual was
unfathomable imagine being one of those
moderate Republicans of some consequence
looking around at what sixteen months of
President Trump has wrought watching Fox
and Friends refreshing the news sites
from the latest national security
debacle would you decide each morning to
remain in the Republican Party the
absence of Republican moderates among
both elected officials and intellectuals
associated with the party willing to
openly join or work with the Democratic
Party suggest that the power of
partisanship remains overwhelming even
among those Republicans who profess the
strongest aversion to partisanship well
I am anti-partisan in the sense that I'm
not going to need your vote for a
Republican just because they're a
Republican I am a conservative you have
to back my values that's the way this
works but that's the point I am a
conservative and I don't support leftist
values why would I go hang out with
Chuck Schumer or Nancy Pelosi just
because I think that president Trump's
record with women is abominable why
would I do that how does that make any
sense at all my whole point is that I
don't think Trump is conservative in his
personal life I don't think that he's
conservative enough on certain social
issues so my solution is to go to the
party that says you should stab a baby
in the head and suck its brains out one
day before it's born that's my solution
how the hell is that a solution see
here's the thing Democrats don't
understand this folks on the Left don't
understand this you know there's this
really interesting chart that's been
done for years by Gallup and it shows
the overlap in ideas between the two
parties and what it looks like is
basically two sort of mountains that are
Criss that overlap a little bit right so
you'll have the one that's the
Republican Mountain then they'll have
the Democratic Mountain and you see that
the shape of the mountain changes a
little bit over time because it flattens
out in certain places and arises in
certain places the reason being that the
views inside the parties change well
since 2010 the right has basically been
stagnant the right has had the same
ideas now that it had in 2010 the left
however has moved dramatically to the
left dramatically remember in 2010
Barack Obama still endorsed traditional
marriage okay that only came later the
same-sex marriage stuff that was only
eight years ago not only that Barack
Obama never in 2010 would have talked
about the idea of forcing churches to
perform same-sex ceremony
or forcing bakers to cater same-sex
weddings you certainly Barack Obama
probably would have used the language
and abortion of safe legal and rare the
Democratic Party doesn't do any of these
things all pro-lifers have been forcibly
excluded from the Democratic Party at
this point and then folks on the Left
are wondering why Republicans don't join
them even if they don't like what Trump
is doing because they still like what
Trump is doing a hell of a lot better
and what you're doing okay Trump still a
lot closer to the values that I profess
then Hillary Clinton or Joe Biden or
Chuck Schumer or any of the rest of
these wild leftists if Democrats want to
know why it is that President Trump can
alienate so many members of his own
party and still get away with it one of
the reasons is because the left has been
so overtly nasty to people who are
conservative so verse ly overtly crappy
to people of conservative bent again why
in the world when I pay attention to a
party who spokesman Joe Biden is saying
that Republicans don't want black people
voting hey Joe Biden actually came out
and said that over the weekend he's
going into the Wayback Machine all the
way back to 2012 when he suggested that
Mitt Romney could not be President of
the United States because Republicans
want to put y'all back in Chains now Joe
Biden is using that same exact sort of
nasty language and then you wonder why
I'd never vote for Joe Biden this is why
I would never vote for Joe Biden right
here you realize just this past year in
24 states the administration's allies
that would have have introduced 60
pieces of legislation or maybe 70 pieces
of legislation to curtail the franchise
but guess what these guys are all about
me yeah Republicans don't want were the
class people voting they don't want
black folks voting okay and he's saying
this to Al Sharpton one of the worst
race baiters in the modern history of
the United States and then you wonder
why conservatives aren't gonna back Joe
Biden or Al Sharpton al Sharpton was a
Democratic presidential candidate as
late as 2004 of course we're not gonna
back this party of course not so
Jonathan Chait you want to know why it
is that we're ignoring your call to join
you because the party that you purport
to represent has no interest in
representing people like me they hate
people like me the may have temporarily
forgotten that hate for five seconds
when I've been critical of President
Trump when I think he's deserved it but
that hate still exists I know it does so
does everybody on the right everybody on
the right knows how Joe Biden feels
about them everybody who's mildly
right-of-center know that
knows that Joe Biden thinks they're
rubes it's just it's so it's so gross
that all these folks on the left their
suggestion is that the only way to
forestall their anger the only way to
prove your moral mettle is to join the
party that espouses everything you
disagree with you don't see people on
the right saying this by the way it's so
weird you never see people on the right
saying things like you know you guys you
really didn't like Hillary Clinton I
didn't get President Trump a try I mean
I assume that you didn't like Hillary
Clinton because she was corrupt and
because she was off-putting but I don't
assume that you agree with with my
principles even voting Democrat your
whole life but here's the point folks on
the Left think that folks on the right
only vote for the right because they are
morally deficient and they can't
understand why if there are people who
didn't vote for Trump which they think
is morally praiseworthy those people
aren't automatically Democrats they see
every question of politics as a question
of character we don't on the right we
see certain questions of characters
questions of character and certain
questions of politics as questions of
politics
okay so meanwhile obviously over the
weekend the other big story is that war
broke out once again in Syria the United
States launched some missiles into into
Syria backed by the UK as well as France
according to CNBC the Pentagon claimed
Saturday the us-led attack on Syria
setback that a regimes chemical weapons
program for years but expert experts
contend those assertions may be
exaggerated on Friday forces from France
Britain and the u.s. launched combined
strikes on three military targets
associated with Syrian President Bashar
al Assad's chemical weapons program
including a research and development
facility outside Damascus but defense
analysts suggested that some of the
dangerous material is probably still
available or relatively easy to
reproduce the damage assessment is
suspiciously quick said Anthony
Cordesman a former Pentagon official
who's an analyst at the Center for
Strategic and International Studies
which is a Washington DC think-tank well
President Trump for his part was very
excited about these strikes which
happened for a late Friday night after
Shabbat was just beginning to start on
the west coast here was president
Trump's tweet quote a perfectly executed
strike last night thank you to friends
and the United Kingdom for their wisdom
and the power of their fine military
could not have had a better result
mission accomplished okay so the mission
accomplished they got him a little bit
in trouble he then had to tweet out his
explanation for why mission accomplished
and his tweet
was quote the Syrian raid was so
perfectly carried out with such
precision that the only way by the fake
news media could mean was by my use of
the term mission accomplished I knew
they would seize on this but felt it is
such a great military term it should be
brought back use often excellent okay
all right sure and the reason people
were upset with the mission accomplished
is because of course george w bush's
mission accomplished banner after the
original Operation Iraqi Freedom the
original invasion in three weeks toppled
the Sam Hussein regime and he put
mission accomplished or his people did
on an aircraft carrier apparently was
members of the aircraft carrier who did
it
and he was ripped for that for years now
Trump is purposefully using that phrase
I don't think he did it because he's
historically knowledgeable I think he
did it because he's historically
ignorant but honestly who cares the
question is was the mission accomplished
and the answer is we don't know because
the actual mission here is to stop
Bashar Assad from using chemical weapons
okay we're not gonna know the answer you
would have said mission accomplished in
April 2017 and then Bashar Assad used
chemical weapons again here is the major
problem the United States and the people
of the United States do not know what we
want our role in the world to be so we
want our world role in the world to be
global policeman do we want to be
operating under the auspices of the old
British Empire where we're making sure
the bad things don't happen around the
world as much as we possibly can
what is our direct interest in stopping
chemical weapons use in ceará I don't
actually buy the argument that's been
pushed by some folks are in favor of a
larger Syrian intervention the use of
chemical weapons in Syria is somehow a
threat to the United States because now
will be more commonly used on the United
States anybody knows they fire on a US
troops we will go to war with you and we
will finish you okay if the United
States want to take out Bashar Assad
like finish's regime the United States
if we wanted to exert the full brunt of
our military the United States could
take up a share Assad inside of a week
like legitimately inside of a week it
would take a while did you clean up
right years to do cleanup but if we
wanted to we could but the fact is that
we're not sure that we want to and we
have this weird bipolar personality
disorder when it comes to foreign policy
we don't care what happens in Syria
until there's a picture on our TV of a
kid choking to death and then all the
sudden we care what happens in Syria
well we're gonna have to figure out
pretty quickly what it is that we think
our role in the world is if we want to
stop chemical weapons usage then
probably this sort of strike is not
going to do it probably gonna need a
larger effort to counter Russian and
Iranian influence in the region and
there has to be the possibility of
deposing Assad
at least crippling his capacity to
expand his growing dominance inside
Syria he's basically won the Syrian
civil war at this point it was a mistake
for us to pull out of Iraq in 2010 2011
that led to the rise of Isis that also
led Bashar Assad to have the excuse to
attack Syrian rebels none of this has
been good but the question is to where
we go from here is a definitional one
what do we want America to do in the
world if the goal here is to stop him
from using chemical weapons the threat
against him and Russia and Iran has to
be great enough that he doesn't do it
again I'm not sure a couple of
airstrikes are gonna do it and if we
want to ensure that people aren't being
gassed on mass then we're going to
actually have to solidified northern
Syria a place where certain progress
actually has been made in the face of
the Assad regime and despite the
intervention of the Turks as well so
it's important for us to define what
exactly our mission is before we declare
mission accomplished unfortunately I
don't think that the Trump
administration has actually done that I
think they say mission accomplished
every time they fire a missile I think
the left complaining about it is
similarly ridiculous they were the ones
talking about pinprick strikes five
seconds ago when Obama was president
okay time for some things that I like
and then some things that I hate so I
have an awful lot of things that I hate
today but I have a couple of things that
I like to start so first thing that I
like Jonah Goldberg his new book is
gonna be coming out very shortly I
believe it comes out later this week
it comes out April 24th so it comes out
the week after it comes out a week from
tomorrow it is well worth pre-buying
it's called suicide of the West how the
rebirth of tribalism populism
nationalism and identity politics is
destroying American democracy so I have
some significant quibbles with Jonah
about his book but his book is indeed a
really good defense of enlightenment
philosophy there's a lot of this going
around lately Steven Pinker has won the
defense enlightenment philosophy I've
recommended on the show journal goldberg
is defending enlightenment philosophy
Jordans book really is lesson about
defense of the Enlightenment philosophy
and more about what happens if we allow
that enlightenment philosophy to fall
apart
now the quibbles that I have with Jonah
I'm going to say it from my own book
which I'm in the middle of writing right
now I'm about two-thirds of the way
through it and it covers a little bit of
the same ground but mostly not the same
ground as Jonah's my big quibble with a
lot of the Enlightenment thinking right
now is that it seems to assume the
history sort of started in 1750 for no
reason that suddenly out of nowhere
sprang the Enlightenment and I just
don't think that that's true I try to
trace the roots back into history try to
figure out where it came from and why it
is that it's important that we keep
though
roots intact Jonah is Jonah's main
contention here is really not about that
his main contention here is that we're
looking at the forcible and willing
suicide of a civilization that was a
brief unique moment in time and if we
don't preserve those values then we're
going to lose it
contention with which I wholly agree
check out suicide of the West by Jonah
Goldberg dead as that is worth checking
out okay other things that I like so
today or last night I guess there was a
Capitals fan who was a little girl who's
waiting right behind the glass and
you're going to see one of the players
here ensure that she gets a puck
apparently she she's not given the puck
he and two of the boys around her are
and then finally he just keeps coming
back and so she finally gets a puck it's
really cute Bret Conolly saw her just
figured I'm gonna make this girl's night
right look here's the problem with being
the shortest kid around that kid grabbed
the first pot from her now look at look
at her face look at this is that the
saddest look at her she's devastated
so Connolly comes back and now that kid
steals a box what are we doing here are
you raising gentlemen or watch and how
Connolly's got to go back he had a third
puck if he could rip that pane of glass
out and just hand it to her he would
which would have been nice because I
yeah yeah what are we Connolly
finally catch it hey that father
orchestrated that because only the cute
little girl was gonna get it he made
sure all three of his kids got a puck
that's good for Connolly it is it is
true by the way there's no question that
that kid the dad knows okay so the dads
getting a lot of flack today actually
because the dad gave the pucks to the
other two boys first before he gave to
the girl it's only to see he's sexist
he's sexist or maybe he's manipulating
right maybe the dad there is grabbing
the pucks and he's making sure that all
three of his kids actually get pucks and
he knows that well the little girl is
really excited about it in two years
she's not gonna care about hockey and
all likelihood but the boys will and
it'll make their life he's gonna ensure
they get pucks even though the even
though Connolly wants to get it to the
little girl good for Connolly in any
case he's a real gentleman and you like
to see when people treat people well
that way okay time for some quick things
that I hate
so bill Mara on HBO he came out over the
weekend and he said that a president
Trump was president in 1938 he would
have loved Hitler and Mussolini
this was 1938 what do you think Donald
Trump is president in 1938 before we
know about the death camps okay I'll
give him that
what do you think he would have been
saying about Hitler and Mussolini which
is what the Nazis in the United States
we're saying in the 1930 okay so let me
point something out the people who are
actually the biggest fans of Mussolini
and Hitler at the very beginning were
folks on the left okay there were a lot
of folks on the Left were big fans of
fascism h:g well in hg wells in britain
a lot of members of the roosevelt
administration were big fans of stalin
big fans of hitler i like that i like
that Marja sort of leaves out stalin
right there because the left of course
was sponsoring Stalin they're big
they're big fans of Stalin but Mussolini
and Hitler read liberal fascism by
Goldberg his other great book and what
you will see is that the left was very
much ensconced with yet they loved the
idea of a centralized power structure
that was going to restructure all of
civilization and therefore change the
nature of man Mussolini and Hill were
very very very popular with the American
left really popular and there's a reason
that Hitler was labeled times Man of the
Year I believes in 1938 so again this is
this is a mystery of history listen I
don't know what trumpet have thought
about Mussolini and Hitler in 1938 there
are a lot of decent people who thought
Mussolini and Hitler weren't that bad in
1938 because they didn't know the first
thing about politics and they didn't
care about fascism and it was before the
death camps there's this revisionist
history that reads back into history the
entire left hated Mussolini and Hitler
Stalin had a treaty with Hitler at this
time in 1938 and Mussolini had a treaty
with Hitler okay all of these people
were allied with one another and the
left kind of liked it not kind of
strongly liked these folks it was only
after Hitler launched war in 1938 1939
that the left began to come around but
that took a while so this is revisionist
history at its finest
okay other things that I other things
that I hate so over the weekend and
there was a report that Colin Kapernick
who's the the former quarterback for the
San Francisco 49ers that he had not been
offered actually the ability to to try
out for the Seattle Seahawk
and he had not been offered that ability
because he still wants to kneel for the
national anthem now listen that is his
choice it's also the choice of the
Seattle Seahawks whether they want to
deal with the fallout from that this
year or whether they actually want fans
in the stands to be able to come and
Cheer sunny Hostin who's one of the
hosts over at the view she says that
that Kaepernick is the greatest of all
time and it's just great what he's doing
[Applause]
Muhammad Ali he is the goat he has put
everything on the line for what he
believes in and that's what a true
American does my feeling is that food
let's remember there's a lawsuit that
the but Colin Kaepernick has filed with
the assistance of my friend Mark Geragos
and he is as well also saying that the
NFL owners have colluded to keep him
from playing and that is exactly what
they've done there have been and the NFL
is going to have to pay Colin Kaepernick
I'm gonna make that prediction right now
because there
okay it's not that they're not keeping
him off the field he is keeping himself
off the field because he's the one who's
deciding exactly how he wants to act on
the field that is Colin Kaepernick's
choice now maybe you like what he's
doing maybe you don't I don't I think
it's stupid I think it's
counterproductive and I want to point
out the Colin Kaepernick only started
the kneeling routine after he was after
he was made a backup he was made a non
star and then he decided to make a name
for himself by kneeling now maybe maybe
it's not quite as cynical as all that
maybe he actually believes what he's
doing maybe that's possible although I
will point out the man has worn socks
depicting cops as pigs on them and
that's ignored by the entire left but
this idea that Colin Kaepernick is some
sort of great civil rights hero because
he was paid millions and millions and
millions of dollars and then he and then
he decided that he was going to kneel
when he became less popular I just find
that a little bit hard to believe I
maybe I'm just being too cynical okay
final thing that I hate so there is a I
mentioned last week that there was this
girl Lizzie Martinez who's asked by a
school official at Braden River High to
cover her nipples with band-aids because
she showed up to school wearing no bra
and I suggested maybe if you're a
seventeen year old girl and you show up
to school wearing a loose shirt with no
bra and your nipples aren't showing
through the shirt that you might know
exactly what you're doing with regard to
dudes
that's not a justification of bad male
behavior but it is to suggest that we
have dress codes in school for a reason
well now she's holding a bra cot with
fellow students on Monday participating
girls can forego their bras and
participating boys could place bandages
over their shirts apparently this is now
a civil rights issue she said it's a
form of silent protest that speaks not
only to what happened at the school but
also what happens around the country
shows besides the incidents on Monday I
think it's been an ongoing issue that
women have these standards they have to
supposedly live up to even with the
women's rights March the me2 movement I
think it's all very relevant okay you
are not part of the me2 movement you are
not sexually harassed or assaulted you
aren't I'm sorry you went to school
dressed inappropriately the
administrators asked you not to dress
inappropriately end of story that is
perfectly within their rights if you
showed up learning no shirt at all and
then the administrators said you know
what that might be a problem would that
also be part of the me2 movement so
unbelievably stupid so unbelievably
stupid but of course all we have to be
outraged about everything including the
dumbest things on planet earth we just
it's if we're not outraged about things
then then I guess that you know what
else are we gonna do with our lives if
we're not outraged about dumb things
like seventeen-year-old girls trying to
not wear bras to school and then
claiming they're victims when the
teachers say put a broad
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow we
didn't have time for Federalist paper
today but hopefully we will tomorrow I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018